This lecture is about the syntagmatic
relation discovery and conditional
entropy.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue the discussion of word
association mining an analysis.
We're going to talk about the conditional
entropy, which is useful for
discovering syntagmatic
relations.
Earlier we talked about using entropy
to capture how easy it is to predict
the presence or absence of a word.
Now we address the different scenario
where we assume that we know something
about the text segment.
So now the question is, suppose we know eats
occured in the segment, how would that
help us predict the presence or absence
of a word like meat?
And in particular we
want to know whether the presence of
eats has helped us predict the presence
of meat.
And if we frame this using entropy,
that would mean we are interested in
knowing whether knowing the presence of
eats could reduce uncertainty about the
meat or reduce the entropy of the
random variable corresponding to the
presence or absence of meat.
We can also ask the question, what if
we know of the absence of eats?
Would that also help us predict the
presence or absence of meat.
So these questions can be addressed by
using.
Another concept, called the conditional
entropy.
So to explain this concept, let's first
look at the scenario we had before
where we know nothing about the
segment.
So we have these probabilities
indicating whether a word like meat
occurs or does not occur in the
segment, and we have the entropy
function that looks like what you see
on the slide.
I suppose we know eats is present, so
now know the value of another random
variable that denotes eats.
Now that would change all these
probabilities to conditional
probabilities where we look at the
presence or absence of meat.
Given that we know eats occured in the
context.
So as a result, if we replace these
probabilities with their corresponding
conditional probabilities in the
entropy function, we will get the
conditional entropy.
So this equation now here.
Would be.
The conditional entropy conditioned on
the presence of eats.
Right?
So you can see this is essentially the
same entropy function as you have seen
before, except that we all the
probabilities now have a condition.
And this then tells us the entropy of
meat after we have known eats occurring
in the segment.
And of course, we can also define this
conditional entropy for the scenario
where we don't see eats.
So if we know eats did not occur in the
segment, then this conditional
entropy would capture the uncertainty
of meat in that content in that
condition.
So now putting different scenarios
together, we have the complete
definition of conditional entropy as
follows.
Basically.
We're going to consider both scenarios
of the value of eats zero or one, and
this gives us the probability that eats
is equal to 0 or 1.
Basically, whether eats is present or
absent, and this of course is the
entropy conditional entropy of meat in
that particular scenario.
So if you expand this entropy, then you
have the following equation.
Where you see the involvement of those
conditional probabilities.
Now in general, for any discrete random
variables X&Y we have.
The conditional entropy is no larger
than the entropy of the variable X, so
basically this is upper bound for the
conditional entropy.
That means by knowing more information
about the segment, we won't be able to
increase the uncertainty.
We can only reduce uncertainty, and
that intuitively makes sense because as
we know more information, it should
always help us.
Make the prediction and it cannot hurt
the prediction in any case.
Now what's interesting here is also to
think about what's the minimum possible
value of this conditional entropy.
Now we know that the maximum value is
the entropy of X.
But what about the minimum?
So what do you think?
I hope you can reach the conclusion
that the minimum possible value would
be 0 and it will be interesting to
think about and in what situation will
achieve this.
So let's see how we can use conditional
entropy to capture syntagmatic
relations.
Now, of course this conditional entropy
gives us directly one way to measure
the association of two words.
Because it tells us to what extent we
can predict the one word given that we
know the presence or absence of another
word.
Now before we look at the intuition of
conditional entropy in capturing
syntagmatic relations, it's useful to
think of a very special case listed
here, that is, the conditional entropy
of
the word given itself.
So,
here we listed the this
conditional entropy in the middle.
So it's here.
So what is the value of this?
Now.
This means we know whether meat occurs
in the sentence and we hope to predict
whether the meat occurs in the
sentence.
Now of course this is zero because
there's no uncertain there anymore
Once we know whether the word
occurs in the segment we will already
know the answer for the prediction.
So this is 0.
And that's also when this conditional
entropy reaches the minimum.
So now let's look at some other
cases.
So this is a case of.
Knowing the and trying to predict the
meat and this is the case of knowing
eats and trying to predict the meat.
Which one do you think is smaller?
Note that a smaller entropy means
easier for prediction.
Which one do you think is higher?
Which one is smaller?
If you look at the uncertainty, then in
the first case the doesn't really tell
us much about the meat, so knowing the
occurrence of the doesn't really help
us reduce the entropy that match, so it
stays as fairly close to the original
entropy of meat.
Whereas in the case of eats,
eats is related to meet, so knowing
presence of eats or absence of eats would
help us predict wether meat occurs so
it can help us reduce entropy
of meat, so we should expect the
second term, namely, this one
to have a smaller entropy.
And that means there is a stronger
association between meat and eats.
So we now also know when this w is
the same as this meat then the entropy
conditional entropy would reach its
minimum which is 0?
And for what kind of words would it
reach its maximum?
Well, that's when this W is not really
related to meat.
like the, for example, it would be very
close to the maximum, which is the
entropy of meat itself.
So this suggests that we can use
conditional entropy for mining
syntagmatic relations.
The algorithm would look as follows.
For each word W1, we're going to
enumerate the overall other words W2,
and then we can compute the conditional
entropy
of W1 given W2.
And we thought all the candidate words
in ascending order of the conditional
entropy, because we want to favor
a word that has a small entropy, meaning
that it helps us predict the target
word W1, and then we can take the
top ranked the candidate words as words
that have potential syntagmatic
relations with W1.
Note that we need to use a threshold
to find these words.
The threshold can be the number of top
candidates to take or absolute value
for the conditional entropy.
Now this would allow us to mine the
most strongly correlated words with a
particular word W1 here.
But this algorithm does not help us
mine the strongest K syntagmatic
relations from entire collection.
Because in order to do that, we have
to ensure that these conditional
entropies are  comparable across
different words.
In this case of discovering Syntagmatic
relations for a target word like W1,
we only need to compare the conditional
entropies
For W1 given different words.
And in this case they all comparable
right?
So the conditional entropy of W1 given
W2 and conditional entropy of W1
given  W3 are comparable.
They all measure how hard it is to
predict W1.
But if we think about the two pairs
where we share W2 in the same condition
and we try to predict the W1&W3, then
the conditional entropies are
actually not comperable.
And you can think about this question,
why?
So Why are they not comparable?
Well, that was because they have a
different upper bounds, right?
So those upper bounds are precisely the
entropy of W1
and the entropy of W3.
And they have different upper bounds,
so we cannot really compare them in
this way.
So how do we address this problem?
Later we'll discuss we can use mutual
information to solve this problem.